today we're just crowded in a space
where the easiest thing is to grow it in
illinois or israel and and sell it
domestically but 10 years from now
that's going to change uh and so if
cleverley's can survive that journey uh
it will it will change the way that this
cannabis industry looks in a decade
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode meet kyle
detweiler the ceo of cleverleafs
prior to the integration of northern
swan and cleverleaves in 2019 detwyler
served the ceo and co-founder of
northern swan holdings as well as
co-founded silverswan capital an
investment firm focused on niche and
under-followed sectors he was also a
principal at the blackstone group a
leading alternative investment manager
with 619 billion dollars in assets under
management as an early member of the
tactical opportunities fund mr detweiler
was involved in the management and
served as a board member of seven
investments with roughly a billion
dollars of blackstone capital
mr deadweiler was previously a member of
the private equity practice at kkr
focusing on transactions in the oil and
gas energy natural resource and
healthcare sectors he began his career
as an investment banker at morgan
stanley deathwilder graduated with
distinction from harvard business school
and laude from princeton university
kyle detweiler welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from florida how are
you
doing great how are you doing this
morning i'm doing great thank you very
much the ceo of cleverleafs today we're
talking about cannabis and and you know
clever leaves from my understanding you
know you're looking pretty broadly at
this ecosystem and this emerging market
you know especially in the united states
and and both from a very you know
sustainable and ecological perspective
but also from a business perspective so
i'm really curious to dive deep into the
cannabis industry with you and
specifically clever leaves but but
before all that kyle
share with me a little bit about
yourself and and you know with
everything else that all the really
interesting things you've done in the
past how do you find yourself getting
into the cannabis industry
oh sure well you know i grew up in a
small town in in rural united states uh
in a state called south dakota um i was
a child of the nancy reagan just say no
era
you know i wasn't a very big supporter
of of cannabis i didn't use it it's not
that i i you know had some big
objections to it i just didn't think
that uh you know there was really uh
medical or social value to the product
honestly until uh until my eyes were
really open when i was in my early
thirties and you know i really started
to understand how it had positively
impacted you know number of friends or
even family members
and so i connect that with my career
choice you know for the last uh well
maybe for the decade before i helped
start cleverley's i focused on investing
in
various businesses uh from different
private equity firms so i was largely
working at the kkr uh and and the
blackstone group and i focused on
investing in pharmaceutical companies uh
often where the emphasis was on trying
to create low-cost manufacturing in
places like israel uh southeast asia and
the other half of the time was spent in
the natural resource space and a lot of
that was in agriculture so blueberry
sugarcane asparagus those types of
things and the idea for a lot of those
crops is to move them to the equator
where you can grow it year round you
know have better carbon footprint do it
in a much more environmentally friendly
way
and also hopefully make a higher margin
over the long run and so when i looked
at cannabis you know there really the
simple idea was to combine those two
lessons that i learned in
pharmaceuticals and in ag
to create a more fashion forward
cannabis company and that's what we
built here at cleverley's
what is the cannabis space as you're
seeing it yourself tell me you know your
perspective on the cannabis space you
know and even take me back to when
you're just entering it sort of what was
your observation and what sort of
unfolded in your eyes because obviously
you know the industry is huge but the
world is even bigger and i think people
every day are getting introduced to this
space and are discovering it probably
what you've already discovered years ago
yeah well it's a really complicated
question because the laws around
cannabis change in every country in the
world in every state of the world and so
i really look at the cannabis industry
in three parts uh first there's the u.s
cannabis industry which has a lot of
attention but you know it's still
federally illegal it may be legal at the
state level and so those companies exist
in sort of this strange little ecosystem
where you can't bring product from
california into massachusetts and vice
versa and you know you can't have
reliable banks it's this weird
anachronism
the second industry would be the
canadian industry it was one of the you
know first major countries to legalize
but you know i think most people
understand you shouldn't grow cannabis
in the tundra you know if you thought of
all the competitive advantages that
canada would have over time probably
producing an agricultural product in an
environmentally friendly way it was
probably not the first thing on the list
um and and so the third category of
cannabis of the cannabis industry is
everyone else colombia brazil israel
germany australia you know those
countries are legalizing cannabis in a
federally legal way which means that the
companies can interact you know israelis
can get cannabis from colombia they can
get it from portugal uh they could get
it even from from canada due to canada's
position on trade and so the the
industry is being built from scratch and
so you go back five years ago i think
investors or you know anybody interested
in this space would say hey if i wanted
to get involved in cannabis i'd really
love to go join um you know a really
a really great branded company uh or you
know i want to join a really big
industrial scale producer well five
years ago they didn't exist wow they all
had to get built right so the last five
years i think each of these industry
sections has been um built up
cleverley's is a good example of sort of
like a cargill or
of the sector you know it's trying to be
a big industrial producer but you know
i've seen a flurry of activity from you
know new technology companies you know
different uh ways to you know consume
cannabis different brands um it's been
quite quite quite remarkable incredible
and so if we're looking at you know
clever leaves four years ago
paint me a picture of where you're at
four years ago and sort of what is your
understanding of the market and the pain
point that that clever leaves and you
know at the end amounting to to a very
big success what was that understanding
that you had four years ago and that
conviction
sure i would say you know if you went to
canada's cannabis conference four years
ago uh and i'm going to speak completely
about the fully legal and regulated side
of the cannabis market i won't talk
about the the unregulated market
i would say the the choice for most
participants at that point was do you
grow in canada or do you grow in the
united states that was really just the
main the main question nobody was
thinking about countries like colombia
nobody was thinking at least in the
united states was thinking about scaling
something up in germany why do you think
that is what was blocking people from
looking outside and saying well yeah
great we have us in canada but we have
actually the whole world at our disposal
i think it's probably two things number
one you know people are always focused
on what's in front of them right you
know if you're an american living in
florida or california or new york you
were probably and canada's was still
illegal you were most interested in
seeing that legalization happen so that
you could be part of the product and
that ecosystem at home right that was
what most people are focused on and i'd
say the other you know the second reason
why most americans didn't know what was
going on in in tel aviv for example uh
was was just that it was it was still
emerging right you know the israeli
market has changed quite a bit in the
last you know four or five years and so
you know people kind of heard stories
about it but it was all very small uh or
is very um
you know isolated right you know we were
talking about countries like israel or
uruguay or canada you know they were
just beginning but nothing had really
been built out yet right the israeli
market was a fraction of the size it was
today same with germany
and so that also helped you know keep
people focused on other things
and so so clever leaves what is the role
that clever leaves today plays in the
cannabis industry
yeah so cleverley's mission in in the
space is really to change the way that
cannabis is produced you know most
people are unaware that to produce an
ounce of cannabis in indoor conditions
where you have the tightest
environmental controls and you can make
the buds the biggest and you know
manipulate the colors and manipulate a
lot of different attributes about it
it's just terrible for the environment
so you know one ounce of cannabis
production if grown indoors emits as
much co2 into the atmosphere as a whole
car tank full of gas no right it's it's
it's crazy wow
okay i had no idea
yeah and i think you know most consumers
today you know they also have their
dream with cannabis right right now it's
novelty they just want to get access to
cannabis and then later they will start
learning about the environmental
repercussions of their choices but if
you left cannabis for a second and you
moved into
milk or
protein based meats you know that the
whole purpose of having plant based
meats today is because of this
environmental problem so
we're kind of positioning ourselves
almost as that uh you know beyond meat
of cannabis and thinking about what will
be the future way that consumers want
this and they want it grown in a
sustainable way you know in our sites in
in
in columbia for example we don't have
supplemental lighting we don't have to
contend with snow we don't have indoor
facilities to keep out pests because we
cultivated 8 300 feet of elevation you
know the greatest deviation of sunlight
in terms of you know the number of
minutes a day we get from winter
solstice to somersault is 12 minutes
like so we have 12 hours of sunlight you
know year round and that is where you
know if if god was to create a site to
produce cannabis it would probably go
naturally into a place like uh colombia
and we're going to harness the power of
that
and and spread that cannabis to the
world and so if obviously you know all
this is built on on a greater trend and
a greater ecosystem that is being built
around the world firstly from your
perspective coming from blackstone from
different investment organizations and
going into the cannabis industry i'm
sure that many around you weren't yet
acquainted with what's happening and and
some of it may still be taboo did you
experience any discomfort or any weird
conversations with people as you're
trying to sort of be a part of this
educating the market on what's happening
here
well 100 percent and you know i have to
count myself in that first cap sorry um
i remember
you know my my co-founder brought up the
idea of of looking at the cannabis space
and and i was pretty dismissive about it
and it was before you know i think he
was a little shy at that time about
sharing
what cannabis did for him uh and in his
case you know he he he battles insomnia
and cannabis was really the main tool
that got him through his his twenties um
and and you know i kind of heard that
and it just changed the way you know i
was i was opposed to even trying it um
until kind of i really you know saw that
um
uh you know saw that experience
firsthand and then i went on to and
found another a friend of mine from
college his wife was battling uh what
might have been uh you know terminal
cancer and you know the only thing that
was able to get her through the
chemotherapy was you know cannabis laced
coffee beans you know it helps restore
her
um you know her hunger and ability to
eat it and just you start pieing up
these anecdotes and then your perception
just changes and so i admit i i had it
wrong you know for most of my life i had
it wrong um and when i finally started
to study the data points look at the
research see that cannabis is not really
a gateway drug but that it is an exit
drug in terms of weaning people off of
deadly opioids you know i've i've really
just come 180 on this on this topic
incredible incredible now what role do
you think clever leaves has a fanny in
part of this market education and part
of you know it sounds like you're coming
in now with the really deep conviction
you're coming with all these case
studies and anecdotes that you're saying
well this you know what we're learning
one thing but actually we have this
abundance of examples of how this is
transforming people's lives do you feel
clever leaves has any part in this
market education
100 you know we're doing our best as we
can um uh you know part of the education
is about the environmental consequences
of different decisions of how to produce
cannabis
but another good advantage that
cleverley's has is our cost structure
you know when you don't grow cannabis in
canada and you can grow it instead in
places where it grows more naturally
like colombia you know we lower the cost
for the systems to substantially you
know in canada it costs two dollars a
gram
to make
cannabis in colombia we can do it for
less than 15 cents and so what does that
enable us to do we can kind of we can
pass those savings
on to our clients our customers which
are other big cannabis brands and then
they can lower the cost of access for
the whole system you know we can lower
the cost for patients um i mean i think
you know a lot of people out there will
have
[Music]
strong opinions about
generic pharmaceuticals for example
are they good things are they bad things
and i would say you know we can leave
the ultimate conclusion up to society to
decide but generic drugs are cheaper
which means they can get in the hands of
more patients and go and treat more more
conditions and i think that's really
what we can we can do to cannabis now
we're just starting on our journey you
know we face a lot of headwinds as a
company you would not think it would be
difficult to do what we do but you know
we are the first company to ever
legally export cannabis from colombia i
mean you can imagine the the the history
around this is is is i can only imagine
pretty strong um
and so we have to change regulatory
paths we have to get airlines
comfortable with taking our product and
so we're on that mission we just have to
gain that mission of acceptance and then
once it's accepted i don't think anyone
in the world questions hey
will a cannabis company that is 90
lower in operating costs than almost
everyone else in the world be a
successful business model in 10 years
everybody agrees that's gonna work out
okay but it's just really like the
hiccups of the next year or two that we
have to uh get over
what part of this journey do you find
most exhilarating you know as an
entrepreneur as a leader now the service
of this publicly traded company what is
the most exciting part of this whole
puzzle
um i don't know i would say you know
we're really just trying to do things
completely different and for the first
time um what you know my favorite quote
of of elon musk's is that you know the
value of what you create is direct you
know inversely correlated to the
difficulty of the challenges you
overcome
and there are many other easier business
models out there in cannabis than what
we're trying to do if you want to make a
quick buck you know you should start a
cannabis company in california or you
know florida you know try to grow it in
as you know little of a regulated
environment as you can and you'll you'll
be able to sell it it's a question of do
you sell it at you know five dollars a
gram or three dollars a gram based on
the quality cleverley's fights every day
on whether or not its product can even
get out of the country um and and so
you know i kind of come back to this
theme that what we are doing today looks
impossible people look at our financials
and say kyle well you know look at
there's all these other cannabis
companies that make much more revenue
than you why don't i go buy those yes i
agree you know if you looked at us based
on you know financial metrics you know
like in in the early 1990s when
blockbuster was a big movie rental
company in the united states where most
americans walked in and got the new
james bond movie or whatever um you
could see cash flow you can see revenues
you can you can walk into a store and
then along came a company like netflix
that said you know we're gonna change
all that we're gonna ship you the cds
and eventually they would go you know
completely get rid of cds and go into a
digital medium you know that company was
losing money it didn't generate you know
the types of revenues that blockbuster
did and i really think that's another
example for our business today we're
just crowded in a space where the
easiest thing is to grow it in illinois
or israel and sell it domestically but
10 years from now that's going to change
and so if cleverley's can survive that
journey
it will it will change the way that this
cannabis industry looks in in a decade i
love the vision of you know we're not
building another blockbuster we're
building the neck we're building the
netflix of of cannabis and and and
looking at it from a
insanely challenging perspective and it
sounds that you know coupled with the
beginning of of our conversation talking
about you know the the way that you're
entering this position and the the
conviction that you have about this
industry it sounds like you're also
carrying quite a bit of responsibility
with yourself on leading this company
and feeling the responsibility of sort
of leading this revolution that that is
imminent to happen and and you almost
want to be the one who is who is doing
this for the world right
uh-huh i i guess so i guess that's
that's how i'm gonna that's my job yeah
but you know i'm really you know i just
i'm uh i'm a manifestation of all of the
visions and the hopes of everybody here
at
at cleverley's and what they're we're
trying to accomplish so i wouldn't i
wouldn't say i'm special in any uh any
respect i just um you know i'm in in the
face and trying to push this campaign
globally right what what if what
surprised you about you know this
journey over the last four years what's
been really surprising you
about either the cannabis market about
you know running this organization
taking it public going through the
challenges something non-trivial
it's very lonely um you know my job is
tricky but our but our business is is
also very lonely like there's not
there's really no other company like
cleverley's out there uh that that
exists and so
you know when it comes to raising
investor capital because we are a you
know we're a startup that is you know
five years old but we're still a startup
and we've got to raise we've got to
raise money we've got to explain to the
world what we're going to do with that
capital um and and most investors say
well i've never seen anything like yours
right why don't i just go buy you know
gti or canopy growth right i understand
those models right they make revenue
like great
those are much easier things and it's
really hard for people
to understand our business and in some
ways our business could also be viewed
as competitive there's there's a reason
those cannabis companies don't want a
company like cleverley's to succeed
because if cleverley succeeds and we
have you know one of the largest
production centers in the world in
colombia and in portugal and you don't
grow cannabis in the united states
anymore well what did they spend half a
billion dollars building you know that
that investment they made is obsolete if
we succeed right so
um i did not anticipate how
how lonely and
potentially almost counter-intuitive
the success of our company is in the
eyes of many of the uh industry
i love it if you had to think of
some inspiring moments or some forms of
inspiration that you derive as you go
through these challenges that you
described before and it sounds like
there's a lot of challenges still ahead
and
where do you gather your personal
inspiration from
i remember my the most emotional moment
i've ever had the company was right when
we were we were going public and
you know just a couple of days before
that um i had learned about
uh one of my um you know
childhood friends
uh his uh his son
uh had you know hopped in the car with a
bunch of his buddies they were gonna
drive out to the mountains and go
camping in the middle of the night and
one of his friends you know wanted to
stop the car at a friend's house to pick
something up was was sort of what
happened
and
ultimately that you know this this
encounter went went wrong and you know
someone ran out of the house uh towards
the car and started firing a gun
and a couple of bullets uh rang out and
you know one of them struck my childhood
friend's
uh son
in the head and he was pronounced dead
at the hospital a couple hours later
and you know
this this this this friends uh son of
mine um
had gotten in the car with some friends
that wanted to go
uh buy some marijuana
uh and it was still illegal in my home
state and you know this entire
like
our our mission is not done right this
is still happening this is happening to
friends of mine it's happening to
friends of people listening to this
podcast
uh we have a long ways to go and
this is the kind of violence or just the
ecosystem we don't want to deal with
when when when our kids grow up and and
so you know i can't even measure success
on a quarter or two if cleverley has a
good quarter yes that's great but this
is the big problem that we're trying to
solve we have to eliminate this mark of
violence out of society and turn this
into a
a product that can
not only
um you know eliminate a black market but
also heal people um so we're still at
the very very beginning of that journey
but that was probably the most emotional
moment uh in the last five or six years
kyle this is exactly why i call the show
20 minute leaders and i appreciate your
leadership and your insights and thank
you for the inspiration over these 20
minutes i learned a lot i i'm leaving
here with with much more energy than i
came in and that is exactly why i'm
doing this so thank you very very much
for everything best of luck with you i
believe it's best of luck with the
mission that you're on really making you
know making a healthier ecosystem making
the world better both ecologically
sustainability but also just in terms of
our perception and our and our behavior
so thank you very very much and stay
safe and stay healthy
[Music]